j'aurais d'abord commencé par dire que
c'est un grand plaisir pour moi d'être
ici
oui merci avec ce petit détail technique
ça va être ça va être mieux je vais
parler d'intégration de données
hétérogènes et riversale génériques
alors évidemment le titre est comme ça
un petit peu difficile à comprendre mais
je vais d'abord faire un zoom sur la
river saint jean gay c'est pour ça que
je suis venu avec mon hélicoptère
on a beaucoup de moyens ici vous pouvez
le voir et je vais essayer d'illustrer
un petit peu tous les concepts qui se
cacher ce mot qui n'en principe doit
parler à pas mal d'entre vous et je vais
essayer d'aborder sa d'un point de vue
un peu un petit peu recherché aussi un
contexte recherche appliquée
un contexte plutôt industrie alors tout
c'est tous ces planches que j'ai vous je
vais vous présenter ont été réalisés
dans le contexte je suis ancien
chercheur à huit essais dans le
département gym des systèmes mécaniques
et je fais partie du laboratoire
roberval ici et j'ai créé avec mes
collègues un laboratoire commun entre
une société et l'utc qui s'appelle dumex
donc la société ça peut être delta
cannes et au vous aurez quelques infos
aussi concernant 7,7
cette aventure donc l'arrivée à saint
jean et ring évidemment je pense que ça
parle à tout le monde l'idée c'est
partir d'un petit produits physiques
comme ça alors là je suis venu avec un
tout petit avec un tout petit
hélicoptère mais il faut imaginer un
jour le faire avec un vrai pourquoi pas
et en faire une maquette numérique
c'est-à-dire une virtualisation 3d une
image en trois dimensions sur ordinateur
de cet objet mais 7,7 mock-up cette
maquette numérique et doit être
intelligente et je vais essayer de vous
expliquer ce que veut dire ce terme
intelligent tout simplement en quelques
mots on va essayer de récupérer tout ce
qui va se cacher derrière la maquette
numérique
réel et la maquette numérique fait comme
ça c'est à dire avec des dimensions et
puis des matériaux etc tout ce qui se
cache derrière
donc vous l'aurez compris de la maquette
numérique vers le produit physique
ce sont les activités design et
d'industrialisation et de production et
la ravine saint-gilles ring celle
inverse tout simplement d'un point de
vue plutôt études techniques logiciels
mais aussi recherche le processus de ré
vers saint jean peut se s'expliquer
selon ces quelques quelques figures que
j'ai illustré
l'idée simplement démonter le produit
utilisé des techniques de
photogrammétrie prendre des photos
d'objets venir assemblez les photos de
manière à pouvoir par exemple refaire
cette petite coque et puis ou aussi
utiliser des systèmes de mesure par
laser ou que scanner armes qu'on a ici
habité c est utilisé tout ceci pour
refaire des surfaces représenté sous la
forme d'un modèle blue ici deux ans
maillage petit hélicoptère qui est une
une géométrie morte mais qu'est ce que
je fais de ces géométrie morte il ya
tout un travail ensuite allé chercher
faire des mesures puis refaire une
maquette numérique au sens industriel du
terme on à la petite vue éclatée
derrière qu'il illustre d'un point de
vue industriel
l'arrivée à saint jean et ring et se
justifie en considérant le cycle de vie
d'un produit un produit il est conçu
déjà il ya le marketing design ensuite
il est conçu de manière détaillée on va
à l'industrialisation l'industrie visé
par don va penser à le produire et on va
préparer tout tous les assemblages et
chaînes de production etc
il ya toute une chaîne de fournisseurs
derrière et puis il ya sa vie l'arrivée
à saint jean va intervenir à trois
endroits
tout d'abord au niveau design le celui
qui vient le plus souvent à l'esprit
quand je présente mes travaux de
recherche c'est celui de l'analyse de la
concurrence donc ça va permettre
censément de faire du benchmark des les
cons
prendre les ce qui va se cacher derrière
les les détails techniques et les
innovations techniques d'un produit la
deuxième chose ça concerne des des
produits qui ont une très longue durée
de vie c'est le cas il ya 40 ans on
n'utilisait pas les ordinateurs comme
aujourd'hui avec la 3d etc
donc il ya des produits qui sont
toujours en fabrication mais qui n'ont
pas eu la chance entre guillemets
d'avoir eu cette continuité numérique
donc l'idée c'est si on veut changer les
procédés faire un peu d'innovation en
fabrication en production remonter le
produire elles dansent dans son image
numérique au niveau fabrication aussi on
va intervenir va intervenir arrivèrent
saint-gilles ring pour faire ce qu'on
appelle la comparaison entre le à ce
design et le has made tout simplement
pour contrôler la production pour
contrôler les dimensions de la pièce
et puis en sortir une nomenclature
vérifier le bon assemblage des pièces
par rapport à ce qui avait été conçue
non plus à 10 ans il troisième chose
dans la vie du produit ça ça concerne
majoritairement l'aéronautique
aujourd'hui mais pas seulement mais ces
essais c'est vraiment sur ce point là
c'est plus frappants essayer de garder
une image numérique de l'objet donc une
maquette numérique qui évolué au cours
du temps pour voir les évolutions
temporel donc la cfr la maquette
numérique 10 à ce design à smaïn times
alors nous on recherche à habiter c'est
avec mes collègues de delta cadets et du
laboratoire roberval on va essayer de
faire d'arriver à sebring un petit peu
différemment c'est à dire on va utiliser
bien sûr toutes les techniques de
photogrammétrie de laser de scanner mais
on va aussi essayer d'aller chercher
toutes les données autour du produit
qu'ils vont nous permettre de faire
cette maquette numérique ici au bout de
l'image dites intelligentes
c'est à dire avec tous les
toutes les intentions de conception
possible toutes les dimensions les
mesures et les techniques associées pour
ça on va intégrer ce qu'on appelle des
données hétérogènes
donc ça peut être des plans de
maintenance des photos des rapports
techniques des textes pleins de choses
tu mens nous aider à construire une
maquette numérique intelligent alors je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails des
time je vais simplement vous montrer les
concept est sûr qu on travaille donc
voici les données hétérogènes comme je
l'avais explicite et on va prendre un
petit exemple ce petit hélicoptère bell
est constitué d'une quarantaine de
composants donc s'imagine bien si je
fais 40 ce cas nous si j'utilise un
scanner qui va me permettre de tout
avoir
il va falloir que je sois capable de
supporter pour l'expert en rivers
engineering l'aider à les identifier
quels sont les composants manière en
temps masqué et aller lui chercher les
valeurs dimensionnelle je prends
l'exemple de cette petite violette
je vais d'abord entrer dans une étape où
je suppose que je connais déjà j'étais
jeune maquette numérique d'un ictère
parce qu'en général générale
industrielle
il connaît son produit il veut
simplement le maintenir et voir le
compare aux parents par rapport au réel
on va rentrer dans une phase de
capitalisation on va aller chercher la
signature de l'objet et de ses
composants deux types de signature
d'abord une signature topologique ont
pas simplement aller chercher la
connectivité entre les surfaces de
l'objet est ici représentée sous la
forme d'un graphique et puis la
signature dit fonctionnel en utilisant
la mise en plan on va pouvoir aller
chercher par des orientations très
surface ici par exemple les deux alésage
doivent avoir des axes parallèles
donc cette exigence fonctionnel on l'a
transcrit en signature et tout ça et
renseignant une base de données de
composants vient le cas donc du coup
d'arriver à saint jean de la petite
hélicoptères ici qui est fait j'ai
scanné j'ai fait juste un focus sur la
petite violette en utilisant des
algorithmes de
reconnaissance de formes basiques donc
ils vont me permettre de détecter les
surfaces canonique c'est à dire des
plans les six dans les sphères qui se
trouve sur la biellette je vais pouvoir
créer sa propre signature de connexion
donc les ne représentent les surfaces
les aides je représente est connecté à
ce graphique
je vais pouvoir ensuite faire un match
avec tout l'ensemble des composants qui
se trouve dans la base de connaissances
et essayer de trouver la corrélation
entre les deux ça va me permettre de
dire le système va me permettre de dire
à l'expert henry vers saint jean doit
dire oui
ici je te montre c'est une bielle et
maintenant je vais te révéler quelles
sont les valeurs dimensionnelles et les
secrets qui s'y cachent
alors comment en base de données j'avais
la signature fonctionnel qui a été
associé la stature de connectivité g
pouvoir faire un match naturel
c'est-à-dire bien tout simplement être
capable d'aller identifier les exigences
fonctionnelles directement dans la 3d et
pouvoir faire l'extraction
d'informations la mesure directement sur
le nuage de pas donc ça veut dire que
j'ai supporté tout ce process un peu
manuel à l'heure actuelle où un expert
en reverse engineering doit ouvrir le
nuage de points le coupé faire ces
mesures manuellement lâché celui
automatisé ceci en supportant tous
toutes les étapes on va dire routinière
récurrentes qui apparaissent alors à la
fin on va faire ça sur toutes les pièces
ce scanner et on va ici vous avez sur la
ce qu'on appelle l'engineering bill of
materials la nomenclature du produit à
ce design qu'on connaît et puis la
nomenclature has made with my town qu'on
m'a réussi à recréer alors évidemment on
n'est pas encore capable de pouvoir
créer la maquette numérique comme je
vous ai présenté tout à l'heure au début
dé slag mais on va être capable de
générer cet homme en clôture et déjà
d'aller révélé quelques informations d'
expertise un tel que des orientations
des longueurs d épaisseur et c'est alors
je vois que j'accélère un petit peu ces
parages faire un peu plus court que les
autres par évidemment là l'exemple il
est assez simple puisque j'ai quarante
composantes mais d'un point de vue
réel la vie est beaucoup plus complexe
donc là on est on parle plutôt
d'automobiles de navires d'avion qui
bien sûr on 3000 4000 voire dix mille
composants et donc toute l'ambiguïté ici
c'est de pouvoir faire de la rivière
saint jean à partir de données
hétérogènes et de supporter tous les
efforts routiers tous les besoins
les besoins en algorithmes
d'un point de vue domaine on mélange en
fait la reconnaissance de pattern
l'informatique et la mécanique puisque
la signature fonctionnelle ne peut se
faire qu'avec des connaissances en
mécanique
et puis dernière la dernière figure ici
que je que je représente
c'est celui du bâtiment vous savez que
le bim je sais pas ce que vous avez
entendu parler du bim building
information modeling est pas arrivé en
france est déjà d'actualité d'ailleurs
et la gemmi l'image du centre
d'innovation ou aussi le bâtiment aura
besoin de riversale gering et
d'intégration de données hétérogènes
pour suivre au fil du temps la maquette
numérique et éventuellement va révéler
des vétusté sur des pièces voilà
effectivement voilà je vous remercie
pour votre attention s'il fait un petit
peu plus court que notre speaker juste
pour finir si vous voulez avoir d'autres
informations sur ce que l'on fait donc
le logo de la société atac avec laquelle
on travaille
et puis le site web du du laboratoire
commun donc digital mocap formule xp3
intégration directe pour utc point fr je
vous remercie de votre attention